ils viennent des villes alentours de
l'aérodrome de toussus le noble après
une manifestation en 2009
les riverains ne battent le pavé il
estime que les différentes avancées pour
réduire les nuisances sonores liées aux
mouvements ne sont pas suffisantes
c'était 2001 très particulière avec un
déconfinement complètement anarchique
anarchique
à tel point que la lah comité de la
commission consultative de
l'environnement a vraiment pris la
mesure de cette situation et les
autorités ainsi que les élus se sont
engagés à prendre des mesures fortes
pour faire face à cette recette
explosion de trafic et ce qu'il en a
accouché en 2021 est extrêmement
décevant
ce qu'on veut c'est vivre paisiblement
dans notre belle vallée de chevreuse
c'est tout simplement ça aujourd'hui il
ya des solutions il ya des aéro clubs
qui ont acheté des avions vertueux
essais des avions qui font pratiquement
pas de bruit et il ya quand même deux
avions électriques mais en fait ces
solutions là en fait elles sont très peu
utilisées l'union des aéro clubs de tout
sur great la surenchère et appelle à
continuer le dialogue
elle rassemble sept aéro clubs et près
de 1000 pilotes
il faut voir que tout suit le noie pas
totalement innovateur en termes d'avions
nouveau plus silencieux déjà on a mis en
place depuis quelques années au sein des
heures au club
beaucoup des dix ans qu'on appelle très
silencieux et au delà de ça on est
quasiment dont les premières plateformes
à utiliser des avions électriques
l'aérodrome de toussus le noble connaît
120000 mouvement chaque année avec un
pic à 135 milles pour l'année 2010